[Music]
hi so i'd like to talk a little bit
about the people who make the things we
use every day
our shoes our handbags our computers and
cell phones
now this is a conversation that often
calls up a lot of guilts
um imagine the teenage farm girl who
makes less than a dollar an hour
stitching your running shoes or the
young chinese man who jumps off a
rooftop
after working overtime assembling your
ipad
we the beneficiaries of globalization
seem to exploit these victims
with every purchase we make and the
injustice
feels embedded in these products
themselves
after all what's wrong with the world in
which a worker on an iphone assembly
line can't even afford to buy one
it's taken for granted that chinese
factories are oppressive
and that it's our desire for cheap goods
that makes them so
so this simple narrative equating
western demand
and chinese suffering is appealing
especially at a time when many of us
already feel guilty about our impact on
the world
but it's also inaccurate and
disrespectful
we must be peculiarly self-obsessed to
imagine that we have the power
to drive tens of millions of people on
the other side of the world
to migrate and suffer in such terrible
ways
in fact china makes goods for markets
all over the world including its own
thanks to a combination of factors its
low costs
its large and educated workforce and a
flexible manufacturing system
that responds quickly to market demands
by focusing so much on ourselves and our
gadgets
we have rendered the individuals on the
other end into invisibility
as tiny and interchangeable as the parts
of a mobile phone
chinese workers are not forced into
factories because of our insatiable
desire for ipods
they choose to leave their homes in
order to earn money
to learn new skills and to see the world
in the ongoing debate about
globalization what's been missing
is the voices of the workers themselves
here are a few
my mother tells me to come home and get
married but if i marry now
before i have fully developed myself i
can only marry an ordinary worker
so i'm not in a rush
when i went home for the new year
everyone said i changed
they asked me what did you do that you
have changed so much
i told them that i studied and worked
hard if you tell them more they won't
understand anyway
even if i make a lot of money it won't
satisfy me
just to make money is not enough meaning
in life
now after i get off work i study english
because in the future our customers
won't be only chinese
so we must learn more languages all of
these speakers by the way
are young women 18 or 19 years old
so i spent two years getting to know
assembly line workers like these
in the south china factory city called
dongguan
certain subjects came up over and over
how much money they made
what kind of husband they hope to marry
whether they should jump to another
factory
or stay where they were other subjects
came up almost never
including living conditions that to me
looked close to prison life
10 or 15 workers in one room 50 people
sharing a single bathroom days and
nights ruled by the factory clock
everyone they knew lived in similar
circumstances
and it was still better than the
dormitories and homes of rural china
the workers rarely spoke about the
products they made and they often had
great difficulty
explaining what exactly they did when i
asked luchinmin
the young woman i got to know best what
exactly she did on the factory floor
she said something to me in chinese that
sounded like chili
only much later did i realize that she'd
been saying qc
or quality control she couldn't even
tell me what she did on the factory
floor
all she could do was parrot a garbled
abbreviation in a language she didn't
even understand
karl marx saw this as the tragedy of
capitalism
the alienation of the worker from the
product of his labor
unlike say a traditional maker of shoes
or cabinets
the worker in industrial factory has no
control
no pleasure and no true satisfaction or
understanding
in her own work but like so many
theories that marx arrived at
sitting in the reading room of the
british museum he got this one wrong
just because a person spends her time
making a piece of something
does not mean that she becomes that a
piece of something
what she does with the money she earns
what she learns in that place and how it
changes her
these are the things that matter what a
factory makes is never the point
and the workers could not care less who
buys their products
journalistic coverage of chinese
factories on the other hand
plays up this relationship between the
workers and the products they make
many articles calculate how long would
it take for this worker
to work in order to earn enough money to
buy what he's making
for example an entry level line assembly
line worker in china
and an iphone plant would have to shell
out two and a half months wages
for an iphone but how meaningful is this
calculation really
for example i recently wrote an article
in the new yorker magazine but i can't
afford to buy an ad in it
but who cares i don't want an ad in the
new yorker and most of these workers
don't really want iphones their
calculations are different
how long should i stay in this factory
how much money can i save
how much will it take to buy an
apartment or a car to get married
or to put my child through school
the workers i got to know had a
curiously abstract relationship
with the product of their labor about a
year after i met liutin min
or min she invited me home to her family
village for the chinese new year
on the train home she gave me a present
a coach brand
change purse with brown leather trim
i thanked her assuming it was fake like
almost everything else for sale in
dongguan
after we got home min gave her mother
another present a pink dunian burke
handbag
and a few nights later her sister was
showing off a maroon
sports sack shoulder bag
slowly it was dawning on me that these
handbags were made by
their factory and every single one of
them was authentic
min's sister said to her parents in
america this bag sells for three hundred
and twenty dollars
her parents were both farmers looked on
speechless
and that's not all coach is coming out
with a new line two one nine one she
said
one bag will sell for six thousand
she paused and said i don't know of that
six thousand yen or six thousand
american dollars
but anyway it's six thousand
min's sister's boyfriend who had
traveled home with her for the new year
said it doesn't look like it's worth
that much
min's sister turned to him and said some
people actually understand these things
you don't understand
[Applause]
in men's world the coach bags had a
curious currency
they weren't exactly worthless but they
were nothing close to their actual value
because almost no one they knew wanted
to buy one or knew how much it was worth
once when min's older sister's friend
got married she brought a handbag along
as a wedding present
another time after minh had already left
the handbag factory
her younger sister came to visit
bringing two coach signature handbags as
gifts
i looked in the zippered pocket of one
and i found a printed card in english
which read an american classic
in 1941 the burnished patina of an
all-american baseball glove
inspired the founder of coach to create
a new collection of handbags
from the same luxuriously soft gloved
hand leather
six skilled leather workers crafted 12
signature handbags
with perfect proportions and a timeless
flare
they were fresh functional and women
everywhere adored them
a new american classic was born
i wonder what karl marx would have made
of men and her sisters
their relationship with the product of
their labor was more complicated
surprising and funny than he could have
imagined
and yet his view of the world persists
in our tendency to see the workers
as faceless masses to imagine that we
can know what they're really thinking
the first time i met min she had just
turned 18 and quit her first job
on the assembly line of an electronics
factory
over the next two years i watched as she
switched jobs five times
eventually landing a lucrative post in
the purchasing department of a hardware
factory
later she married a fellow migrant
worker moved with him to his village
gave birth to two daughters and saved
enough money to buy a second-hand buick
for herself
and an apartment for her parents she
recently
returned to dongguan on her own to take
a job
in a factory that makes construction
cranes temporarily leaving her husband
and children
back in the village in a recent email to
me she explained
a person should have some ambition while
she is young
so that in old age she can look back on
her life and feel
that it was not lived to no purpose
across china there are 150 million
workers like her
one third of them women who have left
their villages to work in the factories
the hotels the restaurants and the
construction sites of the big cities
together they make up the largest
migration in history
and it is globalization this chain that
begins
in a chinese farming village and ends
with iphones in our pockets
and nikes on our feet and coach handbags
on our arms
that has changed the way these millions
of people work
and marry and live and think
very few of them would want to go back
to the way things used to be
when i first went to dongguan i worried
that
it would be depressing to spend so much
time with workers
i also worry that nothing would ever
happen to them or that they would have
nothing to say to me
instead i found young women who were
smart and funny
and brave and generous by opening up
their lives to me
they taught me so much about factories
and about china
and about how to live in the world
this is the coach purse that min gave me
on the train home to visit her family
i keep it with me to remind me of the
ties that tie me
to the young women i wrote about ties
that are not economic but personal in
nature
measure not in money but in memories
this purse is also a reminder that the
things that you imagine
sitting in your office or in the library
are not how you find them
when you actually go out into the world
thank you
[Music]
thank you leslie that was an insight
that a lot of us haven't had before
but i'm curious if you had a minute say
with apple's head of manufacturing
what would you say one minute one minute
you know what really impressed me about
the workers is how much they're
self-motivated self-driven resourceful
and the thing that struck me what they
want most is education
to learn because most of them come from
very poor backgrounds they usually left
school when they are in seventh or
eighth grade
their parents are often illiterate um
and then they come to the city
and they on their own at night during
the weekends they'll take a computer
class or they'll take an english class
and learn
really really rudimentary things you
know like how to type a document in word
or how to
how to say really simple things in
english so if you really want to help
these workers
start these small very focused very
pragmatic classes
in these schools and what's going to
happen is all your workers are going to
move on
but hopefully they'll move on into
higher jobs within apple
and you can help their social mobility
and their self-improvement when you talk
to workers that's what they want they do
not
say i want better hot water in the
showers i want a nicer room i want a tv
set i mean
it would be nice to have those things
but that's not why they're in the city
and that's not what they care about
what's there a sense from them of a
narrative that
things were kind of tough and bad or was
there a narrative
of of some kind of level of growth that
things over time were
oh definitely definitely i mean you know
it was interesting because i spent
basically
two years um hanging out in the city of
dongguan and
over that time you could see immense
change in every person's life
upward downward sideways but generally
upward if you spend enough time it's
upward and i met people who had
moved to the city 10 years ago and we're
now basically urban middle class people
so the trajectory is definitely upward
it's just hard to see when you're
suddenly sucked into the city it looks
like everyone's poor and desperate but
that's not really how it is
certainly the factory conditions are
really tough and
it's nothing you or i would want to do
but from their perspective
where they're coming from is much worse
and where they're going is hopefully
much better and i just wanted to give
that context of what's going on in their
minds not what necessarily is going on
in yours
thanks so much for your talk thank you
very much